تسعى السلطات العراقيه الى وقف تدهور سعر
صرف الدينار امام الدولار والحد من
تداعياته على الاوضاع المعيشيه
والاقتصاديه لا سيما لجهه التسبب بركود
الاسواق وارتفاع اسعار السلع فقدان
الدينار نحو عشره في المئه من قيمته وفي
اقل من شهر دفع رئيس الوزراء محمد شياع
السوداني الى استدعاء محافظ البنك المركزي
لوضع اجراءات تقطع الطريقه على المضاربات
وتسهل تمويل التجاره الخارجيه لدعم
استقرار الدينار مجرد ارتفاعا اهل المواد
والتجار وتستغل ويضاعفون المواد يعني
الايه
ضعفها اكثر غلوه الدولار
احنا بدنا نجيب يعني اني حتى له 400 راتبي
500 راتبي ما يكفيني انا مره كبيره
الاسواق اذا كانت السلعه ام الربع صارت ب
500 فهذا الفقير الكاسب يوميا وين يروح
رغم هذا الارتفاع الجنوبي باسعار الصرف لم
تنجح اجراءاته حكومه السوداني بالسيطره
على قيمه الدولار امام الدينار الامر الذي
ولد مخاوف لدى الشارع من السياسه
الاقتصاديه للبلاد في قادم الايام
البنك المركزي من خلال بيانه اكتفى
بالتعليق على اسباب ارتفاع سعر صرف
الدينار امام الدولار بعوامل داخليه واخرى
خارجيه تقف خلف هذا الارتفاع من دون ذكر
التفاصيل لكن الخبير الماليه والاقتصادي
عبد الرحمن المشهداني فصل لنا الاسباب
الرئيسيه انخفاض قيمه الديناري امام
الدولار الاسباب الحقيقيه انه البنك اتخذ
مجموعه من الاجراءات اللي تخص عمليات
التحويل الخارجي ليس فقط للعراق وانما لكل
دول العالم انه معلومات تفصيليه عن
الحوالات النقديه وهذا هو سبب الاساسي
كبير في الحوالات النقديه لتمويل التجاره
اتجاه التجار الى تمويل همم تجارتهم عن
طريق الشراء من السوق النقديه وتحويلها
بشكل نقدي او عبره
مراقبون اشاروا الى ان بنوكن عراقيه متهمه
بتهريب العمله الى كل من ايران ولبنان
وتركيا وسوريا تعمل كواجهات لجهات سياسيه
هي احد اهم الاسباب ايضا وانها باتت قريبه
من قائمه العقوبات الامريكيه اذا ما
استمرت بتهريب الدولار الى خارج البلاد
سامر الكبيسي العربيه بغداد